innerhalb weniger monate ist mit masten
zu einem der stärksten symbole unserer
gesellschaft geworden für einige
menschen zu einem symbol der gefahr
angst gar apokalypse an das symbol von
schutz und rücksichtnahme und für manche
wiederum zum symbol der bevormundung
entrechtung und unterwürfigkeit und egal
zu welcher gruppe durchzählen magst ich
wette dass auch du deinen enkelkindern
mal passieren lässt die wir in den
jahren des corona virus überall eine
maske tragen mussten und bei
zuwiderhandlung schwere strafen drohten
gleichzeitig auch eines der unzähligen
amateur videos auf denen polizisten
masken verweigerer jagen zu boden reißen
und nieder prügeln wie schwerverbrecher
[Musik]
und dann siehst du ihnen stolz ihr habt
ja so gut sieht nur was für harte zeiten
wir damals durchleben mussten aber
aber was wenn ich dir sagen würde dass
die weltgesundheitsorganisation
whu den ersten monaten der pandemie von
tragen von nase mundschutzmasken strikt
abgeraten
[Musik]
vielleicht hast du das ja schon
vergessen oder verdrängt aber es gab
eine zeit in der viele epidemiologen und
wissenschaftsjournalisten lernen videos
gedreht haben um darin zu erklären warum
der keine masken benutzen sollten selbst
christian drosten der top corona berater
der bundesregierung sah damals keine
wissenschaftliche grundlage für eine
empfehlung zum tragen von masken als
schutz gegen das corona beer und bereits
damals legten sowohl youtube als auch
andere internet plattformen genaue
regeln zur unterdrückung von saic news
über das corona virus fest eine dieser
regeln lautete das beiträge und
kommentare den empfehlungen der whu auf
gar keinen fall widersprechen dürfen
schließlich sei die whu doch die höchste
gesundheitsbehörde der welt und wenn es
jemanden gebe der sagen könne was in der
welt der medizin wahr oder falsch ist
dann ist es doch die
weltgesundheitsorganisation
damals wurde also für einige zeit die
behauptung was tun würden vor dem komma
virus schützen eindeutig als
desinformation gewertet entsprechende
inhalte wurden durch die fakten schenker
als fake news markiert und von den
plattformen gelöscht ja allerdings
änderte die whu wir wissen ja später
dann ihre meinung um nicht weniger als
180 grad es ist klar dass sich gerade
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse mit
fortschreitendem forschungsstand ändern
können denn dies ist ja gerade eines der
grundprinzipien von wissenschaftlichkeit
und aufklärung wie also können wir uns
in diesen unendlich vielen abstufungen
von waagen lüge und er sich dauert einen
faktenlage orientieren kann man hawks
ist wirklich zensieren ohne die
meinungs- und informationsfreiheit zu
beschneiden heute werden wir all diese
fragen beantworten aber zuerst wollen
wir hierzu einen kurzen blick in die
geschichte werfen
[Musik]
es gibt zwei konzepte wie bei der
debatte über zensur und fake news immer
vergessen und unterschlagen werden das
erste ist dass wir nicht nur über
meinungsfreiheit sprechen sondern auch
die arbeit gut existenzgrundlage sehr
vieler menschen nehmen wir zum beispiel
die sozialpolitik in unsere videos
ließen nicht nur sehr viel schweiß und
herzblut nein von den werbeeinnahmen
unserer kanäle ernähren sich auch realen
menschen und für einige von ihnen
stellen sie ihre einzige lebensgrundlage
dar
weil youtube eines tages plötzlich
beschließen würde unsere kanäle
abzuschalten dann wären wir über nacht
aus dem geschäft das wäre so als würde
plötzlich von einem tag auf den anderen
alle einkaufszentren der welt
beschließen ihre zara filialen für immer
zu schließen tausende von menschen
würden ihren job verlieren und auf der
straße landen aber nicht nur das ein
weiterer großer fehler denn viele
teilnehmer dieser debatte begehen liegt
darin dass man alle big tech konzerne
über einen kamm schert dies wird der
komplexität dieser organisationen jedoch
überhaupt nicht gerecht und wenn man die
unterschiede zwischen ihnen nicht kennt
ist man kaum in der lage das problem
qualifiziert zu lösen in wahrheit
spricht mir nämlich über drei völlig
unterschiedliche unternehmen mit
verschiedenen backgrounds und kulturen
hier sehen wir youtube ceo susan
wojcicki facebook ceo mark zuckerberg
und last but not least twitter chefs
deutlich merkt ihr jack dorsey biz gut
denn er wird in dieser geschichte eine
wichtige rolle spielen denn wie soll ich
sagen du kannst dich ja das sprichwort
dass der schein trügen kann nun glaubt
jersey ist ein beispiel dafür dass der
schein manchmal gar nicht so sehr trübt
aber darüber reden wir später jetzt
wollen wir uns erst mal kurz das
phänomen fake news vorknöpfen
[Musik]
wenn du nicht mehr wissen was wahr ist
es macht dich überraschen aber es sind
keine erfindung des internet zeitalters
wir könnten wahrscheinlich bis er mit
prähistorischen zeiten oder das
tierreich zurückgehen aber sehen wir uns
mal kurz ein prägnantes beispiel aus dem
jahr 1898 an elia brach der spanische
kubanische krieg aus ein krieg in denen
die vereinigten staaten die kubanische
seite unterstützen
und all das begann wegen eines
gefälschten artikels in einer zeitung
für morningshow ich bin mir sicher dass
dieser name die ehrlich gesagt aber
viele von euch werden von seinem gründer
gehört haben william randolph hearst und
kennt ihr auch höchst berühmten satz den
er folgendermaßen wörtlich zu sein in so
einer liste sagte bier liefert die
bilder und ich liefere den krieg william
randolph hearst gründe des managers was
heute als verschwörungstheorie gegen die
presse abgestempelt wurde ist damals
jedoch nachgewiesenermaßen genauso
passiert gleichermaßen wurden ja auch
viele andere böse gerüchte die ja
eigentlich viel zu schlecht klingen um
wahr zu sein im laufe der jahre und oft
erst nach ablauf der geheimhaltungs
frist der betreffenden akten als fakten
bestätigt die muster sind auffälliger
weise immer sehr ähnlich und wer glaubt
sie würden sich nicht bis heute
wiederholen muss schon über ein sehr
naives oder obrigkeitshörigen gemüt
verfügen trotzdem es gibt heute einen
entscheidenden unterschied oder lehre
das internet aber was bedeutet das
konkret 0 vor allem dass immer mehr
menschen eine medienplattform zur
verfügung steht über die sie selbst ein
globales publikum erreichen können
anders ausgedrückt der wettbewerb bei
der verbreitung von information und
desinformation ist so groß wie nie zuvor
[Musik]
noch vor 20 jahren gab es in jedem land
ein paar überregionale zeitungen dieses
haltungen teilten sich das publikum und
dem werbekuchen mit ihren einnahmen
finanzieren sie große belegschaften und
große druckmaschinen wenn du den
redaktionsräumen einer traditionellen
zeitungen gesehen hast du wirst du
feststellen dass es sich um richtige
fabriken handelt die presse ist quasi
eine fabrik zur herstellung von
zeitungen und ich versichere dir dass
diese fabrik nicht billig ist die
redaktion einer zeitung wie die new york
times dann hunderte von mitarbeitern
beschäftigen doch diese traditionellen
medien konkurrieren jetzt mit
online-zeitungen der anteil an den
werbeeinnahmen wird immer geringer aber
die großen traditionellen medien haben
weiterhin eine menge rechnungen zu
bezahlen
hinzu kommt ein weiterer faktor nur 30
prozent der zeitungsleser gehen auf die
homepage der zeitungen um die artikel zu
lesen die meisten klicken nur auf
einzelne nachrichten diese in sozialen
medien finden all das erklärt dass das
hektische rennen um mehr klicks absolute
priorität genießt alles andere kommt
erst mit großem abstand danach und
deswegen stoßen wir so oft auf
schlagzeilen wie diese kastrieren von
online-pornografie erzeugt so viel co2
wie belgien überleg mal ein visual
politik video wie dieses erfordert tage
lange recherche das sind stunden arbeit
falsche oder nicht besonders sorgfältig
recherchierte nachrichten sind billiger
zu produzieren
in den meisten fällen ist die arbeit in
wenigen minuten erledigt aber sie können
genauso viel oder sogar mehr traffic
erzeugen der schlüssel dafür liegt in
der bestätigung der ideologischen
vorurteile des zielpublikums alle
beiträge welche diese wichtigste
bedingung erfüllen während als tatsache
angesehen gelesen und mit anderen über
soziale medien geteilt und ich weiß was
du denkst all das ist ein problem aber
es sind ja keine fake news im
eigentlichen sinne wir alle wissen
jedoch dass es echte freaks gibt das
heißt nachrichten die nicht nur aus dem
satz flüstern sind sondern schlichtweg
fälschungen vieles davon wird sogar auf
websites veröffentlicht welche das
layout bekannter zeitungen perfekt
imitieren hier ein beispiel singapur
setzt auf eine offizielle crypto währung
und führt sie als offizielles
zahlungsmittel ein angeblich bsi nur um
auf nummer sicher zu gehen nein diese
nachricht ist nicht von der bbc sie
stammt von einer website welche die bbc
schlicht und einfach initiert es handelt
sich um eine lüge die doch für viele
menschen so glaubwürdig daher kommt dass
sie sie einfach glauben und nicht
hinterfragen und die eigentliche frage
ist wer hätte interesse daran eine
seriöse zeitung zu imitieren um
falschmeldungen zu verbreiten der würde
überdies so plump vorgehen um die
öffentliche meinung zu manipulieren
die antwort dazu finden wir wie so oft
in der politik und zwar in der politik
eines bestimmten landes
[Musik]
ganz genau die rede ist von mütterchen
russland im gegensatz zu cia und
pentagon ist man im kreml wohl der
ansicht seine propaganda ziele auch ganz
unkompliziert ohne bis ins kleinste
detail ausgearbeitet fälschungen und
verschwörungen erreichen zu können es
gibt unzählige beweise für die vielen
oft sehr primitiven fake news und bot
kampagne der russischen regierung mit
dem sie versucht die politik anderer
länder zu manipulieren
und nein in diesem fall regel nicht über
die us wahl 2016 natürlich hat russland
versucht auch diesen wahlkampf zu
manipulieren aber egal wie viel mühe
sich der kreml gegeben hat es ist eben
sehr schwer mit den us medien zu
konkurrieren aber nicht alle länder
verfügen über eine derart mächtig und
professionelle medienlandschaft holt
diese leiden am meisten unter den
auswirkungen dieser fake news attacken
sehen wir uns zum beispiel die
baltischen staaten an überleg mal in
diesen kleinen ländern gibt es eben nur
relativ schwachen medien mit winzigen
budgets den kreml reicht eine kleine
investition um dort mächtige propaganda
medien zu schaffen die mit den lokalen
locker konkurrieren können in riga der
hauptstadt lettlands gibt es deswegen
sogar ein spezielles nato zentrum zur
bekämpfung von desinformation und hier
fangen wir an über ernste themen zu
sprechen macnews.de zu einem politischen
problem geworden ein problem das viele
mit gesetzen lösen wollen aber wie genau
soll das gehen nun das werden wir jetzt
mal unter die lupe nehmen
[Musik]
ortega kämpfen gegen lügen also wenn du
dachtest dieser titel seien bereits ein
schönes oxymoron ein widerspruch in sich
dann warte ab was jetzt kommt also was
meinst du welches land war eines der
ersten gesetze gegen fake news erlassen
hat nämlich einen moment um die antwort
gut zu überlegen also 3 2 1
russland verabschiedete gesetz zum
verbot von fake news und
beamtenbeleidigung im internet hast du
das nicht kommen sehen und glauben nicht
dass dieses gesetz so ein weiteres stück
papier ist im mai 2021 drohte russland
twitter zu verbieten wenn er sich nicht
an sein gesetz halten sollte oder ende
führte diese ganze geschichte dazu dass
russland internetprovider dazu
aufforderte die
übertragungsgeschwindigkeit von twitter
im ganzen land zu drosseln und du wirst
sagen okay das ist eben russland da
regiert ein autokrat und wir wissen ja
aus den nachrichten dass diese die
opposition und vom regierungskurs
abweichende meinungen eben rigoros
unterdrückt was aber geht in der
demokratischen welt ab dann müssen sie
ja gar nicht mal so weit gehen
deutschland
[Musik]
in unserem letzten video über zensur
haben den erzählt dass die deutschen
behörden schon seit langem journalisten
an den pranger stellen und nein es geht
ihnen dabei nicht nur darum neonazis
nicht zu wort kommen zu lassen die jagd
auf angebliche fake news ist
mittlerweile total außer kontrolle
geraten zumindest wenn wir damit die
demokratische kontrolle im rahmen einer
pluralistischen erhältlichen
grundordnung meinen schau dir mal
folgende meldung rein deutsche
finanzaufsichtsbehörde erstattete
strafanzeige gegen financial times warum
stellt ihr deutschland die altehrwürdige
financial times an den pranger ganz
einfach weil sie den wirecard skandal
aufgedeckt hat und das hat so manchem
deutschen politiker nicht besonders
geschmeckt wenn du mehr über die ganze
geschichte wissen wir haben sie bereits
vor fast einem jahr hier auf visual
politik in einem video für dich
aufbereitet der link zum video findest
du in der beschreibung und oben rechts
hinter dem symbol und du weißt ja das
wäre auch personalpolitik viele abstruse
verschwörungstheorie nicht besonders
mögen denn oft handelt es sich bei ihnen
einfach nur um gedankliche parasiten die
mehr schaden als nutzen anrichten aber
so sehr wir uns eine heile welt wünschen
in der gut und böse class unterscheiden
sind so dass wir uns guten gewissens auf
die richtige seite stellen und danach
ruhig schlafen können so sehr müssen wir
auch zugeben dass diese vorstellung
vollkommen an der realität vorbeigeht
und immer ein frommer wunsch bleiben
wird
[Musik]
denn viele skandale wie watergate von
kin notebooks die erfundenen
massenvernichtungswaffen oder eben der
deutsche wirecard skandal wurden
zunächst auf basis von gerüchten
enthüllt und diese gerüchte wurden von
staat und mainstream ob von der mehrzahl
der medien oder selbsternannten
faktencheck als verschwörungstheorien
als böse des informationen von
vornherein diskreditiert natürlich
dürfen wir auch nicht vergessen dass die
wahrheit über diese skandale nur
deswegen irgendwann ans licht der welt
gekommen ist weil es eben in den usa
eine starke investigative
presselandschaft gibt und gesetzes zur
informationsfreiheit durch welche die
akten über diese regierungs
verschwörungen wenigstens mit ein paar
jahrzehnten verspätung offengelegt
wurden und genau hier kommt die große
debatte ins spiel stellen fake news ein
problem da nun auf jeden fall wenn sie
wirklich fix sind aber wonach sollen wir
das beurteilen können wer hat die
kompetenzen das recht uns vorzuschreiben
was die wahrheit ist können wir zum
beispiel blind darauf vertrauen dass die
weltgesundheitsorganisation sagt können
wir den aussagen der deutschen
finanzaufsichtsbehörden blind vertrauen
sollen wir denen viele ideologen aus
verschiedenen ländern vertrauen des
versicherten dass das proma virus kein
größeres problem als eine saisonale
grippewelle darstellen würde oder er
jenen welche zeiten es würde dutzende
millionen menschen binnen kürzester zeit
dahin raffen nun jeder hat das recht
fehler zu machen aber genau deshalb ist
ist so gefährlich einigen wenigen
institutionen die macht zu geben alles
zu zensieren was sich selbst verlegen
halten denn es kann ja schon sehr oft in
der geschichte eines landes einer
gesellschaft oder eine ideologie vor
religion eingeschlossen dass die von den
eliten vorgegebene und von der mehrheit
geglaubte wahrheit sich als weg in den
untergang herausgestellt hat und die
einzig mögliche versicherung gegen eine
fatale falsche homogene einheit meinung
sind eben die unbequemen zweifler die
querulanten jene die gegen den strom
schwimmt klar oft liegen sie falsch aber
das ist weniger schädlich als wenn alle
falsch liegen und niemand mehr da ist
der die wahrheit sagt weil er es sich
nicht sagen darf deswegen scheint ja
auch die europäische union weil sie sich
ja irgendwie mit einem mit demokratisch
freiheitlich pluralistischen anstrich
von russland oder china positiv
unterscheiden möchte vor harten gesetzen
zurückzuschrecken die schlaumeier in
brüssel haben sich daher einen kleinen
umweg ausgedacht
die europäische kommission glaubt dass
selbstregulierung der richtige weg sei
um mit reglos umzugehen aber wenn du das
vorige video in dieser reihe gesehen
hast kannst du bereits die gefahren der
selbstzensur denn in manchen fällen kann
sie sogar eine viel schlimmere formen
ausarten als staatliche zensur aber die
eigentliche frage lautet wie könnte ein
solches modell in der realität
funktioniert wirklich erinnerst sind die
drei größten online content plattformen
facebook zu denen auch instagram gehört
youtube das zum google mutterkonzern
alfabet gehört und twitter nun stellt
sich die frage ob sich diese konzerne
irgendwie unterscheiden oder wie es hier
mit der gleichen art profitgierige
bohrloch öl zu tun haben und genau das
werden dem es erst mal näher ansehen
[Musik]
wer zensiert das internet
hast du schon mal versucht ein twitter
konto zu verifizieren es ist mühsam und
spielt keine rolle ob du mehr oder
weniger voller hass wenn du nicht gerade
eine große nummer auf dieser plattform
ist kann die verifizierung seines kontos
echtes problem darstellen twitter eine
der größten social media plattform der
welt die sich so aufführt als wäre sie
eine schwierige disco mit miesen
rausschmeißen und dafür gibt es einen
grund
[Musik]
twitter hat 5500 mitarbeiter weltweit
facebook 60.000 und alfabet mehr als
135.000 aber was hat das alles mit
fitness zu tun nun eine ganze menge denn
einen filter zu entwickeln der fake news
einigermaßen sinnvoll mäßigt ist sehr
teuer und erfordert eine armee von
programmierern youtube kann sich das
leisten andere unternehmen müssen auf
andere fragwürdige methoden
zurückgreifen und hier kommen wir wieder
auf das bild vom anfang zurück schau dir
die verschiedenen kinos an von youtube
facebook und den von twitter dadurch
vorstellen jack dorsey der von mehreren
finanzmedien als einer der schlechtesten
sie aus den vereinigten staaten
bezeichnet wird
und die eine vorstellung davon zu geben
sogar die eigenen aktionäre von twitter
planten interne wollten um ihn
rauszuwerfen aber warum ist dieser mann
so schrecklich nun wenn wir von
profitgier gesprochen haben so ist diese
nicht der einzige mögliche quelle des
bösen und der sektor sie wollte
eigentlich von anfang an dass ein
unternehmen keinen gewinn macht die
ursprüngliche idee war dass twitter eine
art wohlige stiftung im stil von
wikipedia sein sollte in der tat hat
wird er eine lange tradition der
zusammenarbeit mit der us-regierung und
die wahrheit ist dass jack dorsey sogar
öffentlich gesagt hat dass sein ding vor
allem die politik ist hier an jack
dorsey von twitter hat ein auge auf den
job des new yorker bürgermeisters
geworfen und ich weiß dass viele von
euch denken wo ist das problem seit wann
ist es schlecht wenn ein unternehmen
keinen gewinn machen soll nun das
problem ist ganz einfach wenn du dir zu
fein wisst ihr die hände mit schnöden
mammon schmutzig zu machen aber unter
druck stehst ergebnis liefern kannst du
keine große belegschaft unterhalten und
wenn du dir nicht genügend gute
programmierer leisten kannst und
gleichzeitig damit prahlen willst dass
du eine große tolle
social-media-plattform hast die 100
prozent frei von schädlichen inhalten
ist kommen dann dinge wie folgende
heraus dritter sperrt den account der
schauspielerin rose mcgowan nachdem sie
sich gegen sexuellen missbrauch
ausgesprochen hat es gibt abertausende
von fällen in denen es oft witter ohne
ersichtlichen grund gesperrt wurden
konnten die ein paar tage später dann
wieder aktiviert wurden im jahr 2016
löscht wird das zum beispiel konnten die
russische politiker persiflierten tage
später tauchen sie hier auf und warum
das weiß niemand wird das kriterium für
die löschen von konten sind völlig
willkürlich und intransparent vergleich
dazu hat selbst youtube glasklare regel
auch wenn diese immer noch sehr breit
auslegbar sind zumindest werden sie auf
einem eigenen youtube seite
veröffentlicht außerdem bietet das
unternehmen selbst kurse für videomacher
an in denen erklärt wird was man tun
kann und was nicht und es gibt auch eine
beschwerde des system welches
mittlerweile nicht mehr rein
automatisiert funktioniert ja man
bekommt tatsächlich einen menschen aus
fleisch und blut an die strippe mit
anderen worten wenn youtube dieses video
morgen entfernen würde gibt es zumindest
eins systemen um dem zu widersprechen
und ich kann dir aus eigener erfahrung
sagen dass dieses anspruchs system
durchaus funktioniert ich kenne
persönlich mindestens zwei kanäle die
nach einem einspruch verfahren wieder
hergestellt wurden und übrigens wenn du
dir diese video anschaut einen kanal hat
der gerade gesperrt wurde findest du in
der beschreibung auf den link um ihn
wieder zu aktivieren und da wir gerade
von youtube sprechen ist dieser perfekte
zeitpunkt um sich daran zu erinnern dass
wir hier auf visuelle politik jede woche
neue videos veröffentlichen also
abonniert unseren kanal und drücke auch
die kleine glocke damit du keines
unserer updates verpasst aber zurück zu
unserer geschichte
[Musik]
hat youtube das beste team der welt auf
keinen fall aber zumindest hat ist ein
system im gegensatz zu twitter
tatsächlich gibt es viele kanäle auf
youtube die zwar erlaubt sind es die an
twitter konto aber gesperrt ist
denn die richtlinien von twitter zum
sperren von konten sind so willkürlich
dass sich von land zu land
unterschiedlich sind in den vereinigten
staaten oder europa sind hassrede und
fans der feind in der türkei sind alle
politiker die sich gegen erdogan stellen
dass ein du glaubst mir nicht gut dann
wirf einen blick auf diese nachricht
eine überprüfung von mehr als 700
konnten die in der türkei gesperrt
wurden ergab dass mehr als 600 kunden
personen gehören die mit militanten
prokurdischen bewegungen in verbindung
stehen somit konnten die nicht den im
exil lebenden türkischen islamischen
prediger fethullah gülen verbunden sind
die türkische regierung wirft kühlen und
seinen anhängern eine rolle bei dem
gescheiterten putsch 2016 vor und wenn
das heutige system schon mies
funktioniert dann sieh dir mal die
vorschläge zu seiner verbesserung an
diesen nämlich noch schlechter
worldwatch ein gemeinschafts basierte
ansatz gegen fehlinformationen stellt
sich vor diese strategie für bekämpfung
von bse informationen besteht aus einer
gruppe von tätern die von twitter selbst
ausgewählt werden und danach die tricks
anderen unter beurteilen soll in den usa
testet das unternehmen dieses verfahren
bereits mit 100 moderatorin die nach
eigenen angaben verschiedene
ideologischen background haben sollen
und hier kommen wir wieder auf die idee
vom anfang zurück es geht nicht nur um
die meinungsfreiheit es geht auch um die
arbeit vieler menschen hinter vielen
großen twitter youtube oder facebook
accounts stehen tausende von existenzen
und all das den launen einer gruppe von
menschen zu überlassen die von politik
ideologischen vorurteilen und seien wir
ehrlich persönlichen fähigkeiten
beeinflusst werden ist keine gute idee
mit anderen worten vielleicht sollten
wir uns nicht fragen ob die plattformen
sich selbst regulieren sollten sondern
ob die plattformen nicht er die rechte
der urheber garantieren sollten diese
frage wird in den nächsten jahren sowohl
juristisch als auch politisch
ausgefochten werden
zu letzterem hast du vor allem damit
beitragen indem du für jene politiker
und parteien stimmen welche die
mündigkeit der bürger nicht regulieren
die meinungsfreiheit nicht in einem
engen korridor zwängen wollen bzw diesen
zwang an den medien plattformen in form
von selbstregulierung delegieren daher
die frage an dich bist du der meinung
dass die plattformen sich mehr
anstrengen sollten um dies zu vermeiden
oder sollten sie vielleicht genau das
gegenteil tun und jede art von inhalt zu
lassen sollte der staat nicht er dafür
sorgen dass die internet oligopolisten
die meinungsfreiheit ihrer nutzer nicht
bestreiten dürfen glaubst du dass
twitter facebook und google für solche
willkürliche praktiken ihren nutzern
gegenüber verantwortlich gemacht werden
sollten oder denkst du im gegenteil dass
es sehr wichtig sei gerade in schweren
zeiten meinungs- korridore gezielt zu
verändern und menschen die mit der
regierung und führungseliten nicht an
einem strang ziehen wollen das wort zu
verbieten sie auszusondern damit schon
heute die ganze nation und morgen die
ganze welt ungebremst und über jeden
zweifel erhaben in ein und dieselbe
richtung marschieren kann teile deine
meinung bitte weber mit uns und auch
allen anderen im kommentarbereich ich
hoffe dass wir dieses video gefallen hat
was ja gib uns bitte alle und teils auch
mit seinen freunden was gut und bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]